earth day is friday and springs preserve  plans to continue the celebration right  into the weekend they're holding a earth  day event on saturday that's from 10 a.m  to 4 p.m if you take the kiddos there'll  be a trail cleanup project  sustainability classes as well as  sustainable crafts activity booths and  plenty of food you can make your  reservation for the event on springs  preserve's website and see the  butterflies fly  it's like there's going to be a lot of  fun digging in the dirt  that always feels good if you've never  been to springs preserve you've got to  get over there there's so much there so  much to see yeah yeah should